[Music]  are you buying from a teaching  we are just genuine friendly  we would love to change the way you  think about the biological world  do you want to be a part of this  potential cutting-edge platform if yes  then brace yourselves to get into the  scientific podium  participate in our mixed research  symposium to meet like-minded people and  interesting pieces of different  geographical areas  it will help you to widen your knowledge  pool to find solutions to your problems  be there to present your ideas via the  poster presentation competition  so what are you waiting for  fill out your forms now before it's too  late